he said she said we'll she won't she who
done it who cares just confirmed
Cavanaugh the latest from the hearings
and a reassurance from Senate Majority
Leader Pablo Escobar cocaine Mitch
himself then merriam-webster adds a new
fake word to the dictionary that should
be a lot of fun joseph nicolosi jr. dr.
joseph nicolosi jr. stops by to explain
the difference between gay conversion
therapy and his own work and Arby's
offers to tattoo their corporate logo on
your flesh for absolutely nothing
all that and more i'm michael knowles
and this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
oh so much to get to today so so much I
hope I hope this is the final cocaine
Mitch you're our only hope moment and
this chaos ends with Kavanagh before we
get to all of that and why I think that
the American people are on our side
we've got to thank ring rings mission is
to make neighborhoods safer you know
ring I've talked about ring a long time
and all of your cool friends have it I
actually was just I was having dinner
with another friend of mine the other
night who also has a ring doorbell and
you go up and it's got to way camera and
they can see you and they can talk to
you whether they're inside the house or
whether they're at a Beach and Boca
somewhere it is
security for the 21st century there used
to be neighborhood watch that is old
that is that is not the way of 2018 this
is super cool they have the floodlight
cam which is great too so you know when
when you're trying to break into
somebody's house and I can't that flood
light hits you they have one with a
camera in it it's two-way it's uploaded
right to the cloud you can share it to
your neighbors you say hey there's some
suspicious-looking Sicilian fella
wandering around my neighborhood you've
got to watch out for him and he looks a
little bit like Rachel Maddow and so the
technology is out of the Jetsons and
it's really really affordable you should
get this ASAP it's the ultimate in home
security
powerful HD camera puts security in your
hands right now save up to 150 bucks off
a ring of security kit when you go to
ring.com slash anoles KO wles ring.com
slash Knolls KO wles like Beyonce that
is ring comm slash Knowles guess what's
in the news today do you think it's that
the economy hit an all-time high now do
you think it's that unemployment has hit
an all-time low I think a low since
movin at an all-time low but certainly
since 1969 is it that no here's what's
in the news is Brett Kavanaugh who
allegedly groped a girl when he was 17
or something and she can't really
remember when or how and she just
started talking about a five seconds ago
and it might have not even been the same
guy
[Music]
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah here are the
Democratic senators just utterly making
a farce out of this whole process
take it away senator Gillibrand their
oath and so I believe her I stand with
her she shows up on Monday do you hope
that she should be bullied into this
scenario where it's a he-said she-said
where many members of the committee have
already made up their mind without the
benefit of an FBI investigation where
it's nonpartisan and objective and
without the benefit of corroborating
witnesses being able to testify it's a
sham hearing and I don't think she
should participate in it did you catch
that did you catch that one a hundred
and eighty degree spin I'm what
nauseated just by watching it can we
play that again listen to that again and
so I believe her I stand with her she
should be bullied into this scenario
where it's a he-said she-said where many
members of the committee have already
made up their mind without the benefit
of an FBI investigation where it's
nonpartisan and objective and without
the benefit of corroborating witnesses
being able to testify it's a sham
hearing and I don't think she should
participate in it in case you didn't
hear it even that second time she said I
believe her
I believe the accuser I stand with the
accuser and then she immediately says
that this is a sham hearing because
there are no corroborating witnesses and
many members have already made up their
minds did you made up your mind you just
did that you did that exact thing and
Gillibrand she's she's a snake in the
Senate because everyone thinks she's
laying low and she always think of Chuck
Schumer when you think of senators from
New York you don't think of her but
she's worked her way up into that Senate
seat I mean she is a she is a serpentine
senator and you see that here I mean she
is able to say to utterly contradictory
things with a perfectly straight face
and obviously Jim Acosta can't tell the
difference at all I mean he's just yeah
actually all he's think about is the
moose that he put in his hair this
morning well yeah yeah Jim I think that
looks pretty good I can't so he's it -
is it - uh voluminous I don't know Jim
and then she spouts all of her nonsense
so you
she exposes that to be the Sham the
Democrats are exposing this to be
ashamed they're saying it with their own
words Donald Trump comes in president
from comes in he finally is weighing in
he had been so good he had been saying
okay I hope she testifies so we'll see
what she has to say okay okay now he's
going after her all bets are off he
tweets out quote I have no doubt that if
the attack on dr. Ford was as bad as she
says charges would have been immediately
filed with local law enforcement
authorities by either her or her loving
parents I ask that she bring those
filings forward so that we can learn
date time in place now is it natural is
it perfectly logical that you know is it
necessary that if this attack took place
meaning if drunk teenagers groped each
other in a at a party you know without
and we don't really have any more
details than that if that took place
would she have reported that I'm not
convinced of that I'm not totally sure
that she would have a lot of people who
have been truly sexually harassed in
their work who had been you know and
they they don't come forward because you
just kind of want to forget about it and
move on so on that point that isn't fair
but on the broader point this is a
totally fair tweet we don't know the
date we don't know the time we don't
know the place we don't really know the
people there we don't know the
circumstances we don't know the year we
don't know anything about this it is a
totally uncredible allegation and it's
about time that she either puts up or
shuts up then Trump tweets again he says
quote the radical left lawyers want the
FBI to get involved now why didn't
someone call the FBI 36 years ago of
course on the specific point this
doesn't make sense why would she have
called the FBI this would be oh maybe
this would have been a local law
enforcement matter maybe not even that
depending on how this thing actually
went down it might not have even been
that so so the FBI wouldn't have been
involved but on the point of the tweet
the tweet is perfectly fair and the
reason is when people are watching this
they're seeing FBI accuser assault there
and so what President Trump is doing is
he's very good at the media is just
using those those ingredients he's just
using the terms that are being thrown
around and flipping them on their head
is this perfectly logical no does it
make sense as a matter of
or law enforcement no but what President
Trump is doing now is not making a legal
case he's he's now joining a media
assault on these supporters of
Cavanaugh's accuser and that's perfectly
fine
this actually should have happened a
while ago I thought it was a really
dangerous game to play footsie with all
of this and play along and try to be a
little too clever by half it's an absurd
allegation it's not credible they should
have shut this up days ago and they
should have voted to get Kavanagh
through Punta Busta nothing more get it
done now some people on the right or up
in arms over president Trump's tweets
because he's getting involved I'm not
saying the tweets are that helpful but
they're not they don't hurt who cares
who cares whose mind has been changed on
this issue by those tweets nobody not a
single person and I really really
suspect that most Americans don't put
any stock into these claims they might
say that they put stock into these
allegations because they don't like
Donald Trump and they don't like
Republicans and they don't like Brett
Kavanaugh and they don't like the
Constitution and they want to get this
guy and railroad him and keep him out of
the Supreme Court so they might say they
might play along there might be hacks
but they're pseudo opinion they're
public opinion is not going to be
changed because Donald Trump tweets
about it it doesn't matter it'll say oh
but the optics oh but how it looks who
cares we are so past that we are so past
how it looks we elected Donald Trump
that should have put the end to that
question of playing by these polite
little rules the American people are not
interested in playing by these polite
little rules anymore we're not
interested in this meta strategy of
politicians saying one thing and then we
have to decipher what they really mean
because when you say this it really
means that and then bikies said this to
him and the know if we're in a much more
direct political moment and people are
being much more direct about their
partisan hackery
kirsten gillibrand is a great example of
this she comes out she says I have made
up my mind before you see any hearings
before any investigation and senators
who make up their minds before any
investigation or shams and scam artists
she actually said that in the same
sentence we are in a very direct moment
of power on power this is power politic
here and what is at stake who cares what
happened 36 years ago who cares not me
don't care one little bit is Brett
Kavanaugh a really nice guy yeah it
seems like he is also I don't really
care what I care about is protecting the
Constitution protecting Liberty and
having a serious justice who is willing
to apply the the framework of our
country as it is written and as it was
as it by the definitions and by the
meanings that it had when it was adopted
that's what I want that's what I care
about no it does not matter the
scintillating gossipy tabloid aspect of
this truly does not matter it does not
affect my life one little bit it
happened four decades ago I just don't
care and you shouldn't care either but
Donald Trump tweeted this doesn't matter
we are in power politics time right now
do you support the Constitution do you
not support the Constitution do you
support due process and the rights of
the accused to face their accuser and
statutes of limitations and not just
ruining people's lives on apparently
baseless allegations do you stand with
that the rule of law or partisan hackish
anarchy those are the two options that
you've got guess which side the
celebrities fall down on I'll let you
see dear professor Ford do professor
Ford dear professor Ford we know how
difficult it is to stand up to powerful
people we want to thank you for publicly
sharing your story of sexual violence as
members of the Senate determine whether
Supreme Court nominee bright happy
avital Brett Kavanaugh
should serve as support justice disagree
more justice this context is critical
the behavior you described was wrong
wrong wrong and runs directly counter to
upholding the law of emotive justice he
should not be confirmed he should not be
confirmed he should not be confirmed to
have your truth shared on a national
stage without your position you should
be the decision-maker about how our
story is shared if ever we applaud your
courage in coming forward you are strong
you are a survivor this is a tired
cliché tired tired tired cliché we don't
know anything about this about this case
case so we're going to repeat repeat
repeat repeat simple words and slogans
words words words and and slogan slogans
because we're saying nothing and this is
a parody of the early 2000s PSAs essays
essays this could have been on the onion
this could have been a clay cold or
something John Julianne Moore Moore
Julianne and more okay great but you
believe her okay Julie well if Julianne
Moore believes her
all right he's out get Kavanagh outta
there Julianne Moore has weighed in and
a bunch of other people that I've never
seen before it but I guess they're
celebrities to some people who knows
absurd right and they they've been they
do this all the time that and it always
is meaningless and the American people
don't care they hate this they hate
these things we don't want to be told by
celebrities what we think we don't want
to be told by actresses like Julie
anymore we rejected this in 2016 and we
mock all of these at these ads never do
well and yet the left just keeps making
them because they're living in a fantasy
past that no longer exists all of this
is why cocaine mitches our only hope
cocaine Mitch give me hope maybe you've
watched the fight
you've watched the tactics but here's
what I want to tell you in the very near
future
judge Cavanaugh will be on the United
States Supreme Court
so my friends keep the faith don't get
rattled by all of this we're gonna plow
right through it and do our job I've got
one message for all of the Democrats who
are trying to stop Brett Kavanaugh from
going on the court that is what we're
getting from cocaine Mitch and he's
exactly right to do it he's exactly
right I wish he'd done it a week ago
that is exactly correct this is absurd
these allegations are childish they are
not credible we shouldn't give them one
second ser time we shouldn't have any
hearings we shouldn't have it nothing
not nothing not at all confirm him get
it done all that this air can do is suck
up a whole new cycle which should have
been about how the economy has never
been better thanks to President Trump
well if the experts told us the economy
would crash under Trump it's never been
better Louis joblessness highest market
highs and it's been sucked up by this
stupid Cavanaugh insinuation nonsense
get rid of a cocaine Mitch give it to me
end but by the way the reason cocaine
Mitch is right here is because as we
could probably Intuit from those
Julianne Moore videos the American
people don't believe this they don't I
don't I really don't believe that the
American people think that this woman is
legit and the brick haven't always are
rapists they might or like on Roper or
whatever when he was a teenager and drie
don't know they might say that they
might say that in certain depending on
how a question is asked depending on how
who knows but I really just don't think
it's the case and CNN just learned this
when they they had a panel of people
that they were talking to you know
regular old American civilians and they
said do you believe that Cavanaugh did
it or that Cavanaugh is innocent a show
of hands how many of you believe judge
Cavanaugh when he says this didn't
happen I believe
how can we believe the word of a woman
something that happened 36 years ago we
this guy has an impeccable reputation it
was nobody nobody that has spoken it
will about him everyone that speaks
about him this guy's an altar boy you
know a scout he's you know because one
woman made an allegation sorry I don't
buy it
but in the grand scheme of things my
goodness you there was no intercourse
there was maybe a touch can we really 36
years later she's still stuck on that
had it happened I mean we're talking
about a 15 year old girl which I respect
you know I'm a woman I respect and we're
talking about a 17 year old boy in high
school with testosterone running night
tell me what Boyd hasn't done this in
high school
please I would like to know thank you
thank you ladies thank you five out of
five say they believe Cavanaugh duh duh
I mean come on regardless of what
happened or what didn't happen who
remembers water who was there it this is
so it's so beyond the pale it's so out
of left field it's so out there this is
not to be believed we is so
transparently a political ploy get rid
of it get it done please cocaine Mitch I
hope you're right you're our only hope
we've got to turn now because we've
heard so much sin 2016 and in recent
years about gay conversion therapy and
either movies at about this we are Mike
Pence apparently wants to electrocute
gay people I don't know where the left
got that from but that's what they say
and so you hear these stories about you
know parents making their kids go to -
they call it pray away the gay or
something like that and it sounds really
awful and that seems like child abuse
and that's bad there there is there is a
doctor there are a few doctors who
practice something called re integrative
therapy which is considered the same
thing by the left but dr. nicolosi who
was one of the people who does this
draws a distinction and his his version
of the therapy is that the patients are
in charge they come to him and they say
I don't want to have same-sex
attractions anymore is there anything
you can do to help he says he has a way
to help so we decided to hear him out
here is dr. Nicolosi
dr. Nicolosi thank you so much for being
here it's great to be here so we have
heard in the popular culture
a lot of things about gay conversion
therapy reparative therapy for some
reason the left is all upset at Mike
Pence they say that he electrocutes gay
people I don't know where they got that
from but they they've seemed to be
obsessed with this and there's even a
movie coming out called boy erased with
Russell Crowe and Nicole Kidman I think
about this gay kid whose parents reject
him and he's abused at some Protestant
anti gay camp or something like that I
haven't seen the movie as you can tell
you are a proponent of reparative
therapy or therapy for people who are
gay and they don't want to be gay
anymore but how does your work differ
from everything that we're seeing in the
popular culture we need to differentiate
between two things one term is
conversion therapy no conversion therapy
is a term that's broad it's ill-defined
there's no ethics code no governing body
it's practiced by unlicensed individuals
this is the stuff that we're seeing from
Hollywood but in the work that we do in
our working reintegrate of therapy the
client is in the driver's seat the
licensed psychotherapist uses
evidence-based mainstream treatment
approaches the same treatment approaches
used in other clinics throughout the
world to treat trauma and sexual
addiction and ask those underlying
dynamics or resolve the sexuality
changes as a byproduct our clients
notice significant and lasting decreases
in their same-sex attractions and
increases in their heterosexual
attractions do you find when you're
you've worked with a lot of clients I
know your father was a leader in this
field he's worked with a lot of clients
there's this question that the popular
culture has been debating for years now
which is whether homosexual attraction
is biological or genetic or whether it's
the product of environmental factors or
whether it's the combination of both of
those things now obviously it can be the
product of environmental factors early
exposure to colporteur music for
instance you know many many of those
sorts of things but there does seem to
be some evidence as far as I can tell
that there are biological in nature
netic factors for a homosexual
disposition have you found that is that
what the literature says what what have
you found in your own work there is no
soap
gauging but that's science fiction
here's the science we know that the
brain is capable of something that we
call neuroplasticity in fact there's a
new study released basically every week
demonstrating that the brain has this
neuro plastic capability neuroplasticity
is idea that the brain can wire and
rewire itself based on our life
experiences and with neuroplasticity in
mind why would everybody sexuality be
set in stone so we see that there's
further and further evidence of this and
we also know that the regions of the
brain that are responsible for sexual
preference are the same regions of the
brain that we know change over time I
can tell you this the hundreds of men
that I've worked with in our clinic they
tell me very remarkably similar patterns
in their childhood experiences that they
believe relate to their same-sex
attractions that's interesting and I
wonder too if there is some sort of
spectrum here of people who they're
same-sex attraction is so hardwired that
it isn't going to change and it would be
fruitless to try to change it and people
where it's a little bit in the middle
you know we always hear from lefties and
proponents of the sexual revolution that
there's a Kinsey scale and everybody is
a little bit gay and I don't know
whatever they're saying now one in four
maybe more at my dear alma mater of Yale
University and who knows but is there is
that the case I mean what percentage of
patients would have success with this
therapy which percentage of patients
would not have success and to address
the concerns of the popular culture
could these therapies be damaging to
people or is that a fiction of Hollywood
okay well let's let's start with can
people change what percentage of people
change there's some new data that's
going to be coming up students going to
give us more precise information on
exactly that topic but we need to look
at what's most important which is that
we got a look at the motivations of
individuals who are saying look
homosexuality isn't for me and there are
three reasons that I see in my practice
one individuals who were sexually abused
by someone of the same sex when they
were young resulting in conflict and
confusion and lingering effects of the
abuse and these are individuals who as
adults say they want to resolve this and
we see that with standard trauma therapy
when we focus on treating the sexual
abuse memories these adults often
describe
their sexuality changing on its own the
second is individuals who because of
their closely held beliefs maybe they're
Muslims Jews Christians Buddhists these
are all people who say I believe I was
designed heterosexual and the last is
individuals who they're not religious
they don't even a deeply held belief
they were traumatized but they there
they're here for pragmatic reasons they
say look I tried homosexuality I came
out 10 years ago I find homosexuality
and homosexual relationships compelling
but at the end not release fulfilling
and they wish to explore heterosexuality
and I believe no one should interfere
with that that's their right to pursue
if they choose well this is the irony of
the sexual revolution as they say
everybody should be free to pursue the
sexuality they want to pursue unless I
say that you can't and then you can't
and it's the second one that religious
objection that to me seems like the most
obvious one if people have any variety
of creative sexual preferences say you
know a little slap and tickle here and
there or same-sex attraction or whatever
you can choose not to pursue that there
that this has been true throughout the
history of the church it's certainly
true and other religions as well so it's
that aspect that the patient coming to
you and saying I want to change this
about me is there any way to do it
that seems compelling how do you answer
the charges of these Hollywood movies
like boy erased that portray reparative
therapy or you know I forget the
technical term what is the technical
term they use therapy reintegrated there
too rate of therapy who say that this is
a just a way to abuse children who are
confused about their sexuality is that
is there a only one age group that goes
through this therapy as that age group
changed over time what do you see with
your patients okay so what we see in
reality is very different from Hollywood
so Hollywood has all sorts of depicted
row of everything by the way that's yes
if people are interested not in the
watching a fictional Hollywood film but
watching an actual real life documentary
we just released a film we commissioned
a skeptical Hollywood filmmaker to get
to know the actual clients who've gone
through this therapy the movie is called
free to love it's on free to love movie
calm and this filmmaker goes in and he
asked these individuals who went through
this
therapy the real life people what they
went through what was their success and
what he found is shocking and surprising
it's it's free to love movie.com
yet that's interesting I think people
should yeah definitely check it out
because Hollywood is certainly making
their own movies on this and it would be
interesting to see the other side of it
the other question is about the the
public policy of it all I know that you
were very helpful in having California
pull back on a be 2943 which was going
to ban all of these therapies that would
have the therapies that cover what you
do and why did that get shut down what
was the process of that and what does it
have to do with religious liberty and
what does it have to do with individual
liberty in the country we're quite a few
questions I'll do like yeah so we don't
know the exact reason we may never know
the exact reason why a b2 943 was pulled
by the bill sponsor on the very last day
we don't know exactly but it probably
had a lot to do with a lot of
individuals saying look I was sexually
abused when I was young
don't take my right away to walk away
from homosexuality I don't want to be
kept in homosexuality against the will
against my will or other individuals who
say wait a second the client should be
in the driver's seat of their own
psychotherapy not the government and
this is not the kind of legislation that
would pass I think in court I think it
would it would get torn to shreds
so um what we really need to focus on is
that the clients are in the driver's
seat and the reality that sexuality is
fluid and not fixed these are the most
important points for us to know there's
neuroplasticity neuroplasticity the
brain can change it changes based on our
life experience sexuality is not fixed
for everyone that's a very interesting
point and it's funny too because it
seems that the movement against your
form of therapy and and the sexual
revolution more broadly keeps changing
its mind on this says either sexuality
is entirely biologically determined
that's the I was born this way version
of it and then the other is we can
change whatever we want become whatever
we want I can become a woman or you can
become a man or whatever when when they
talk about child abuse with reintegrate
of therapy or all of the bastardization
z-- that are online
that Hollywood takes on I wonder how
come they never talk about the
transgender hormone therapy being used
on little children we have on the other
side of this political debate left-wing
activists who are advocating that we
chemically castrate children before
puberty how come that has never brought
up as child abuse what are the politics
of this debate and how long has this
been going on okay so the heart of what
you're talking about right now is is
ultimately the the hypocrisy that we are
seeing on the hard left so let's talk
about this in this particular case there
are three examples of real hypocrisy on
the hard left that we're seeing related
to these bills like a b2 943 um you know
these there are these individuals who
say we should just have this is
different between the LGBTQ movement and
the hard left leaders of the LGBTQ
movement these heartless leaders had
been telling us look in terms of gay
rights people should just have the right
to love whoever they want
but with this legislation they're now
trying to take away the rights of
individuals to love whoever they want my
clients are men who want to love women
no one it's right to deny them that the
second is that the hard left has been
telling us no LGBT individuals should
have equal access to all forms of health
care
well what about clients who want to see
me as a licensed clinical psychologist
the third and perhaps the most stunning
is that the there are individuals in the
hard left who welcome people into the
gay community but they will try to block
those same individuals when those people
want to leave the gay community that
bullying that's wrong and in the name of
anti-bullying the hard left have become
the real bulls that's it that's the
point I think that is totally mistaken
because when the mistaken by the left I
mean because when you watch the trailer
for boy erased your heart is just ripped
out of your chest you say these bastards
trying to you know shame this boy and
ruin his life or something but you have
to ask yourself is that what is really
happening and you're in your practice do
teenage boys come in and say I really
want to be gay and you say well you
can't be which is that is that the
reality that we're talking about no we
use we use mainstream evidence-based
approaches to treat trauma and
underlying sexual addictions and as we
do that the sexual
Changez on and so on I'll give you a
quick example of this you know in fact
I'll summarize you know so many of my
clients who have never met one another
they describe remarkably similar
backgrounds and their childhoods things
that are not being to address by
Hollywood my clients consistently report
having distant detached critical
father's higher anxiety sometimes
intrusive mothers and they themselves
were boys who were temperamental II
sensitive if you put these factors
together it seems to increase the
probability that the boy will have
difficulty making that gender identity
shift away from the mother and toward
the father that is typical and young
childhood oftentimes my clients had a
bullying older brother if you put these
factors together it makes it harder
these individuals my clients when they
were growing up girls with their closest
friends they knew girls like the back of
their hands but boys and roughhousing
and my clients felt scared they felt
intimidated by these kinds of behaviors
they didn't know how to connect with
other guys and their childhoods were
filled with getting female attention
affection approval but no male attention
affection approval eventually in puberty
those underlying desires became
sexualized this story is happening again
and again and again and the mainstream
media refused to acknowledge these
individuals and their stories but they
can only do it for so long because the
meet because the Internet
the proliferation of information the
traditional gatekeepers of information
the mainstream media are now being
abolished and films like free to love
and other people's testimonies are
coming out they can't contain this story
forever well I can't wait to see the
film because we've seen the other side
so I look forward to seeing that film
and it is a funny irony that for years
and years we've been told by the left do
whatever you want as long as you don't
do it in the streets and scare the
horses and that's kind of been the
mantra of the last century or so and yet
now we're being told by those very same
people unless you want to do this unless
you want to change sexual behavior
unless you unless you want to for
whatever reason
stop living in the sexual way that
you're currently living so I I think
that really helps to clear things up and
it's it's also funny too because there
are people who call you a quack you know
say there's no the science isn't in the
science isn't settled and
and yet those are the same people who
were saying that a little boy who says
he's a little girl should have chemicals
and hormones shot into his body and
should delay or permanently prevent him
from going through puberty it's a real a
real irony so I really appreciate you
coming on I really appreciate your
explanation and I look forward to seeing
the movie free to love dr. Nicolosi
thank you very much for being here thank
you Michael Hollywood never shows that
guy I noticed it's always some like
wackos and some 20-person town whippin
little kids and stuff very interesting
to talk to him you know my one bit of
skepticism on innate factors is that I
always remember loving girls being
attracted to girls you know from like
probably when I was two years old but
but who knows I don't in a culture that
is willing to chemically castrate
children because of apparent gender
confusion that is willing to pump them
full of hormones and ruin puberty and
ruin their lives it seems perfectly
acceptable for people who want to change
their sexual preferences to go see a
therapist who can try to help them that
seems much more defensible than shooting
kids full of hormones and delaying
puberty so I at the very least those
lefties who are so outraged about
reparative therapy and reintegrate of
therapy maybe take a look in the mirror
before you start throwing stones the
reason I have my laptop up you know that
I hate having laptops up when I'm
talking to people and screens and
everything but there was breaking news I
want to read it right now from the New
York Times headline Rosenstein rod
Rosenstein Deputy Attorney General
suggested he secretly record Trump and
discussed the 25th amendment
it's just came out the story says the
Deputy Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
suggested last year that see he secretly
record President Trump in the White
House to expose the chaos consuming the
administration and he discussed
recruiting cabinet members to invoke the
25th amendment to remove mr. Trump from
office for being unfit story goes on he
was just two weeks into his job at this
point he had begun overseeing the rush
investigation played a key role in the
dismissal of James Caan
me by memo he made the remarks in
conversations with other Justice
Department and FBI officials the people
who have divulged lists in the New York
Times obviously have been insisting on
anonymity so here's the other side of
anonymous sources occasionally they they
turn on the bureaucrats themselves the
people were briefed on the events
themselves by FBI officials including
Andy McCabe then the acting Bureau
director that documented mr. Rosen
Stein's actions and comments this is
what we've been saying all the time this
is what we've been saying since the
beginning when people are talking about
the deep state what they're talking
about is that it's bureaucrats career
bureaucrats unaccountable unelected
officials who decide that they know
better than the American people and
they're going to overturn a presidential
election that is what we're talking
about that it's not a conspiracy theory
that is real now for his part I think
Rosen Stein denies the report but that's
the report who knows what it's worth
it's in the New York Times so take it
with a grain of salt but it is
surprising that they would go after
their own guys like this that they would
run a story that would seem to benefit
president Trump if it weren't true that
is some incredible news
using wielding the power of the state to
undo a presidential election those are
the two groups that we see here we see
it in the cabin all-hearing we see on
every public policy debate we see it in
the election we see it in the deep state
conversation there is one group that
wants to uphold the rule of law that
wants to uphold our Constitution and
defer to people as being able to govern
themselves in America that is one even
if even if the election doesn't turn out
the way that we want it to be even if
it's 2008 or 2012 all over again
want to uphold the rule of law there is
another group that wants to totally
subvert the rule of law that hates the
rule of law that hates the Constitution
that hates the country that hates the
American people they love the they love
humanity and abstract but they don't
like humans when they meet them that
does not trust the American people
doesn't trust us to govern ourselves
those are the two groups and
so they're gonna come up and support 36
year old vagues quasi accusations to
torpedo unimpeachable Supreme Court
nominees they're going to try to wield
the power of the federal government to
undo a presidential election to try to
kick out a duly elected president
they're gonna do everything they can
those are the stakes and we're sitting
here talking about stormy Daniels that's
the national conversation stormy Daniels
mariokart whether the girl 36 years ago
had a beer like Gavin on was it Kavanagh
or this guy who cares those are the
those are the stakes those are the
stakes that we're up against an
incredible story if there's anything
more we'll try to cover it before the
end of the show now we've got to move on
to the culture because Wow well perhaps
in the politics we shouldn't focus on
frivolous things in the culture we have
to focus on frivolous things because
that's all the culture is these days
Merriam Webster's dictionary has added a
new fake word they add fake words every
so often they've added a new one which
is Latin la ti M X latinx lateen X I've
heard it pronounced both ways either way
it's unpronounceable and this is because
the word Latino which is refers to
Hispanic people that's sexist because
Latino that in in Romance languages in
Spanish and Italian the gender-neutral
gender is the masculine gender so in the
this is true you know in Italian you
could have libro is a book right that's
a masculine word it ends in O typically
if it ends in O it's masculine if it's
an A it's feminine that isn't always
true but that's because those languages
have genders the social justice left in
America liberal white people in America
have decided this is unacceptable
so to help those been itíd poor Hispanic
let tinks people down below the border
we're going to go in and totally change
their language because their language
isn't acceptable anymore the first time
anyone even mentioned this was about ten
years ago 15 years ago I know I think
about 2004 so 14 years ago
and there were a few options there was
lateen a at lateen
at sign like you know an email address
but that's absurd because that's just a
random simple so then they added an X
which is a way that Spanish people would
not end their words that's just not how
that language works we will you'll
explain the silliness behind all that
and talk about sexy Handmaid's Tale and
discuss tattoos and the greatest fast
food restaurant America but
unfortunately you've got to go to daily
wire.com you can't just keep getting
everything for free this is a capitalist
country for now though it might not be
for much longer go to daily wire it is
ten bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the intro
claim ensure you get the men Shapiro
show you has their questions a mailbag
your bump up this is what matters this
is what matters
the leftist tears tumblr the mmm that
that was like the original recipe for
coca-cola if you know what I'm talking
about
Mitch if you know what I'm saying Senate
Majority Leader McConnell thank you for
that batch of leftist tears go to daily
wire comm we'll be right back with a lot
more
[Music]
I have two distinct thoughts on the
latinx on the one hand it's absurd it's
absurd and ridiculous to try to remove
gender from language it because we're
trying when we try to remove gender when
we try to abstract gender from sex when
we try to say that there's no such thing
as sexual to everything we know it butts
up against reality we know that isn't
the case we'll get to this in a second
too and The Handmaid's Tale we know that
isn't the case we know that there is
sexual difference it feels so tedious
and politically correct and like you're
living in a fantasy and you see this
with people who are PC all the time they
have to constantly preface every single
thing they're gonna say say well I want
and and by the way I just want you to
know that I'm editor but that isn't to
say that I'm a did it and I also and I'm
sorry if puppet didn't shut up just spit
it out I don't have that much time
tell me what you're gonna say so we know
that this is an absurd fantasy world
because sexual difference does matter
and it's in here's in these languages
but then my second thought on the lek
tinks is I love it I love it because it
exposes the left for what they are which
is imperialists they are imperialists
what they are saying is these liberal
white wackos with purple hair in America
are saying hey Hispanic people your
anti-hispanic stop using that language
of yours and use our language to
describe you because we're compassionate
and we're supporting you say what well
then stop telling us to and stop telling
us have to do what a language but I
don't know I was trying it's not a great
Latin accent my tinks accent it's crazy
the way the Engler if you want to refer
to it in English it's Latin
that's it it's not letting no it's not
my Tina it's not latina at it's not
letting X its Latin because we speak
English Latino and what tanks are not
English words until merriam-webster
wants to pretend that they are it's
Latin that's fine when I I don't refer
to Italiano's I don't say like hey yeah
so I was I was down in the Bronx the
other day and I was hanging out with
some of my italiano friends you know I
don't do I say it Italian friends see
surely on old friends you know no nobody
does that
oh I was going you know I was down there
hanging out with niffle say this won't
say means M you can say oh no that's so
stupid
but when it comes to Spanish when it
comes to you
shoes of Hispanic people or Latin people
we have to all of a sudden affect these
crazy accents and and pretend that we're
speaking another language which were not
and then pretend that out other language
is that even a separate language which
exists only in fiction it's crazy they
only do it when it comes to Latin
Americans because it's all about
political ideology I talk about this all
the time it the way they use these words
is 1,000% politically ideology we should
reject it we should laugh at it
speaking of rejecting and laughing at
political ideologies the this is the
greatest story of the day there is a
shop on the Internet
I think it's called Yan decom something
like that which is selling a hands maids
tale costume just in time for Halloween
but you know The Handmaid's Tale it's
those big frumpy red they look like
burkas but they wouldn't call them
burgers because I don't want to be anti
Islam so as giant potato sacks and the
bonnets and everything and they kit you
know but the the difference with this
Halloween costume is it's super sexy
it's this little slip you know you get a
lot of leg it's nice and form-fitting
and the left is so upset about this
because the whole point they're saying
we live in trumps America where women
have to wear potato sacks and it's like
a Muslim country even though we wouldn't
say it's like a Muslim country
we just can't awful and then meanwhile
they the actual version of this which is
selling is this like sexy little number
because women can wear whatever they
want they can dye their hair purple and
who cares it's America it's free do
whatever you want
it totally cuts against their narrative
I'm probably gonna wear this for
Halloween so you might want to shield
your eyes now keep them closed for the
next month and a half or so just a
wonderful thing go out there get that
costume I love these moments where the
left they they're so insistent on a
narrative and then reality just punches
him in the face that is that could be
the the history of the 2016 election but
the and and they're the you know it's
amazing now too because the left is they
still wield cultural power so it's not
like they we can just show them and we
punch them in the face and that's it and
we win because the left wields this
awful power such that they made Yandy
pull it off their site now look the
thing is popular it's
we're having a good time it's a
Halloween costume all that craziness at
Yale a few years ago started because a
professor said people can wear whatever
Halloween costume they want and the
student said how dare you say you can
wear any Halloween costume we're 20 year
old Yale students we can't dress
ourselves and and it became this huge
deal professors lost their jobs now so
Yandy this company I think that's what I
hope that's what it's called it is what
it's called right you Andy they caved
and they pulled it off of their site
which means by the way the ones that
have already been ordered are gonna be
selling for like five hundred dollars on
eBay pretty soon but we can't let the
left get away with this we can't let
them get away with this I think the
whole country is like that panel on CNN
you know or at least a lot of the
country which is hey do you guys care
about this Cavanaugh thing raise your
hand if you don't know don't care move
on but the levee even if they're only 10
of these wacko lefty activists they are
enough to get people to pull it off the
website to get rod roses hey rod
residency trying to get people to throw
the president out of office for no
reason at all they're using the 25th
amendment they're really potent so you
really got to watch out of course I'm
running late today I don't even care cuz
I'd one more story that I want to talk
about this is a big deal so I don't want
you to miss out on a great deal if
you're by Long Beach California tomorrow
tomorrow one day only Arby's
one of the great fast-food franchises
perhaps the greatest Arby's is offering
you an incredible opportunity you can go
to a tattoo parlor and have them brand
the Arby's corporate logo on your body
in exchange for nothing you'll get
absolutely nothing at all that's it
that's the deal that's the deal you
brand their logo on your flesh and
mutilate yourself and that's it just cuz
I bet people are gonna do it I bet
people are gonna do it this follows on
the heels of dominoes in Russia Domino's
Pizza doing the same thing doing a
similar version which as they said if
you get Domino's tattooed on your flesh
we'll give you free pizza for life they
figured like three insane people we're
gonna do this the promo was gonna run
for two months they had to shut it down
after only a few days because everybody
in Russia was doing it they said oh free
pizza yeah I'll destroy my body
they actually there was a Russian one
she was quoted in the Wall Street
Journal Russian millennial she said oh
yeah they would have had a million
people demanding pizzas they had to stop
it
now this requires a little bit of
nihilism I think a little nihilism to
trade your flesh for a piece of cheap
pizza that isn't even that good that but
we shouldn't be surprised to find such a
nihilism in Russia which is renowned for
its multiple suicide games fact one the
most famous suicide game in the world is
called Russian roulette
perhaps we find it there now we're
seeing it even in America though I would
not be surprised if Arby's gets a few
takers because among Millennials but
nearly the lion's share nearly the
majority are getting tattoos I think
it's about 40% now depending on where
you put the age brackets but for ages 18
to 29 38 percent of those Americans have
at least one tattoo and this causes us
to go into the history of tattoos a
little bit tattoos have always been
around humanity I think it was the
iceman the 5000 year old guy that we
plucked out of the ice a number of years
ago had tattoos on him the lombards the
invading lombards in the was at the 8th
century I think they had tattoos on them
the for in the 4th century Emperor
Constantine banned tattooing the faces
of prisoners because he found it to be
unchristian now we now prisoners tattoo
their own faces so it doesn't matter if
they put those little teardrops and
things like that and in popular culture
it's always been acceptable for soldiers
and criminals to have tattoos and I the
reason for that is because those trea if
you're a warrior or if you're a criminal
then hyper-masculinity a sort of
brutality a sort of sheer force and
violence and tribalism is required for
the job
for either good or bad if your soldier
is for good if your criminal it's for
bad but that makes a lot of sense then
in more recent years we've added
cultural acceptability for tattoos that
have some kind of meaning to you so you
know a kid is born and you tattoo the
name or a poem that you really like or
something I kind of see the argument for
that I'm not you know I'm not the most
hyper masculine brutal guy on earth so I
don't have any tattoos never served in
our armed forces or committed a felony
so I've never been able to do it but I
do I do get the argument for that the
thing that we're
me though with Millennials as I see a
lot of them just getting random tattoos
that mean nothing
so I've seen I was at a store the other
day and I saw a retail worker had the
phrase a four-letter word that starts
with s cray written in cursive on his
index finger that's that was his tattoo
I've see I've seen Millennials get
citrus fruit tattooed on their joints
just like a that - you know an orange or
something or a grapefruit or who knows
whatever I've seen friends get just
random geometric shapes tattooed on
their arm why I don't know just cuts
that really worries me that actually
does not you know the other tattoos I
kind of get but the ones that are just
nothing is a celebration of nuf of
meaninglessness and it's a really aim
'less activity and it does indict our
generation you know this generation has
a an increasing number of religiously
unaffiliated people people who don't see
any objective meaning in the world only
subjective purposes that you can give
and sort of fly away that that's a
problem that's a I don't mean who cares
if they've got a tomato on their elbow I
don't really care but what it says about
the culture is that we're really losing
a sense of purpose and you're gonna see
that reflecting your politics you're
gonna see that reflected in your culture
and you know there's only more of the
younger generation coming there are only
more entering the workforce and even
younger than that so we really should
straighten out this issue and we're
gonna do it baby we're gonna straighten
everything out next week this was a long
news cycle week all of this Cavan on
nonsense I'm sure it will continue so
we'll we'll try to get through the next
week on the right foot that's our show
have a good weekend binge season one of
another Kingdom because we got season
two coming up and it is going to be
really really good in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show I'll see you on Monday
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua el vera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018